(air whooshes)
- [Narrator] This program is presented by
University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest UCTV programs.
Also make sure to check out and subscribe
to our YouTube original channel UCTV Prime
available only on YouTube.
(rhythmic synthesizer music)
- Welcome to A Conversation with History.
I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Leon Wieseltier,
who is the literary editor
of The New Republic.
Leon, welcome to Berkeley.
- Pleasure to be here.
- Where were you born and raised?
- Brooklyn, New York.
Deepest, darkest, 1952.
- And looking back, how
do you think your parents
shaped your thinking about the world?
- Oh in many ways
which I'm not prepared
to talk about publicly.
(Harry laughs)
They, well they were, central
fact about my parents,
the central public fact about them,
not the central private fact,
though it was also a central private fact,
is that they came to New York in 1947
as what we now refer to as
survivors of the Holocaust.
So I was raised, you know,
in a small pocket of
Polish Jewish survivors
in South Brooklyn, and that
ramified in all sorts of ways.
I have to say, it didn't,
I don't feel at all distorted
by it or glamorized by it,
and I've written about it very rarely,
very rarely, because,
well for many reasons.
But it colored certain things, yeah.
- And it must, as a young person,
made you very aware of history
and the course of history.
- Acutely, phenomenally,
precociously aware
that everything happened
on this larger canvas.
I mean one of the central
events of the modern world
ran right through my living
room when I was a boy.
So there was always this feeling
that things were being played
out both small but large also.
- And did this lead to a discussion
of public issues and international?
- Yeah, I'd say it did, I'd say it did.
Yeah, my parents were, you know,
the newspapers were on
the table every day.
My first political memory
was on my way home.
I must have been four?
On my way home from the
Yeshiva of Eastern Parkway
and had to pause while
President Eisenhower drove by
to throw out the first
ball at Ebbets Field.
(Harry laughs)
And then a few years later I went to see
John Kennedy campaign outside
a once-famous restaurant
at a place called Kings
Highway in Brooklyn.
Yeah, there was, and of course,
we lived mentally and
emotionally and historically
not just in the United
States but in Israel as well.
So there was always this consciousness of
the immediate European past,
and then the American present,
and the Israeli-Middle Eastern present.
There was a, so yes, our kitchen was.
The kitchen was rather a global place.
- Did you have a good Jewish education?
- I had a very fine Jewish education.
- [Harry] In that.
- I went to a very
distinguished Jewish day school,
a Zionist yeshiva sort of place
where I was instructed by real scholars
and genuine Hebraists.
I had a very, very fine Jewish education.
- And then your undergraduate work was?
- [Leon] Columbia, Columbia College
- And there you really
were exposed to an array.
- I had the richest education
in the history of Columbia, I think.
I mean I was I was obnoxiously
unappeasable about it, too.
But I studied philosophy,
and I studied art history,
and I studied English.
And, but I had, you know, I was born.
If I'd been born five years later
I would have missed many of my teachers.
I was very fortunate.
Lionel Trilling and Meyer
Schapiro kind of took me in.
Paul Kristeller taught me
the history of philosophy.
I mean, there were younger,
remarkable instructors, too.
But I had, I was able to sit
at the feet of some great men
and then continue doing
that later in my education.
I was very fortunate.
- And this was a time when
Columbia really introduced
the Western civilization courses.
- No, no, it was, they were already,
they were already going,
they were going.
- But they were there.
- Yes, C.C., Contemporary Civilization,
and what we called Humanities,
what they now call Lit
Hum, they were still there,
and they were already there.
And they provided the foundation
of most of what I know, I have to say.
They were extraordinary.
If I could take them again, I would.
- And then you went on to Oxford.
- Then I went to Oxford
to Balliol College,
where I studied philosophy,
but didn't complete a degree there
because the philosophy that
was being taught at Oxford
in those years, was in transports of logic
and philosophy of language,
philosophy of mathematics.
I have neither the aptitude for
that nor the interest in it.
But had the great good fortune
to be taken in by Isaiah
Berlin, who became,
towards whom I had filial feelings,
that we became very
close for many decades,
and he had an enormous
impact upon my mind.
- And then back to Harvard?
- Then I went to Harvard to do
a Ph.D. in Jewish History and Religion
I'd always intended to do advanced work
in the history of Judaism,
and there was some very
fine younger scholars.
Younger, I mean in their
forties and fifties at Harvard,
and I was a graduate student
there for three years,
and then at the end of
my third year was elected
to something called the
Society of Fellows at Harvard,
which freed me,
or ostensibly was just
was designed to free me,
from my Ph.D. work, though
I continued some of that.
And then wrote.
When I was at Oxford I
was poor as a church mouse
and began writing
for places like the New
York Review of Books
and the Times Literary Supplement,
and then when I came back
to Harvard, to the States,
to Harvard, I continued doing this.
So I'd always had one foot in scholarship
and one foot in journalism,
which I've kind of reproduced
only on the other side now.
And then wrote a little bit,
got involved in a nuclear debate,
wrote a little book about nuclear weapons
that found a great many readers.
And a lot, and never
completed the scholarly book
I was going to write,
that I planned to write,
about the interpretation
of catastrophe and France
in the French and
German-Jewish communities
in the aftermath of the Crusades.
But some of that material,
and certainly some of the
thoughts about that material,
eventually made its way into Kaddish.
- And we'll talk about that in a minute,
but I wanna, in looking at
your very rich education,
I gather two individuals stand out.
Trilling and Berlin, or maybe more.
- There were more, I mean, I was.
Again I was very lucky.
I mean Trilling had enormous impact on me.
Berlin did.
Meyer Schapiro, the art historian, did.
Absolutely extraordinary individual,
taught me how to look in some ways.
- And is there a perspective that emerged
from these individuals?
I mean, I get the sense that as a result,
you became a liberal
in a traditional sense.
- That's a big question.
I guess I'd have to say the
following, many things emerged.
One level, what emerged
was a lifelong devotion
to the humanities and a great
resistance to scientism,
either in its social scientific
or natural scientific form,
and a great skepticism
about scientific answers
to non-scientific questions.
I also came to believe
as a consequence of,
not so much anything that
was directly imparted to me,
but as a consequence of the
weather around these people,
that I became a kind of
pluralist about human life.
People live in many realms,
and one must be careful
not to import categories from one realm
into a realm where they don't belong,
because that's how
misunderstandings begin.
They left me with a very powerful sense
of the difference between
politics and culture
and of the dangers of synchronizing
politics with culture,
or worse, culture with politics.
They did leave me a liberal,
but a certain kind of liberal.
They were all very distinguished
anti-Stalinist liberals.
They were people who, I mean,
Diana Trilling had an
important impact on me
in this particular
aspect because by example
and through many hours of
conversation when I was young
and not very well-read and rather heady,
a student at Columbia,
she actually showed me what
it was to be anti-Stalin
and anti-McCarthy at the same time.
And I've always taken that as a model,
because there's never just one threat,
and there's never just one enemy,
and there's never just one danger.
And you have to operate on many fronts,
at different levels, at the same time.
And so they were liberals,
but of a very muscular sort.
They were not radicals,
they were not progressives.
I call myself a liberal.
I do not call myself a progressive.
And my progressive friends
certainly don't call me a progressive.
Yes, so they influenced me in many ways.
- And an important dimension
of the latter point
is what you wound up rejecting
and they rejected was
that there was one
totalistic view of the world.
- [Leon] Yeah, yeah.
- And that's what you mean by,
oh, I can be against
McCarthy but not Stalin.
- Everything is not.
The idea that everything is
one thing in the modern period
basically derives from Hegel.
That a single spirit animates
all the manifestations
of human culture, all of,
all of human expression.
This I was taught,
and as I began to read and
think, became clear to me,
was a colossal and very
consequential error.
But having said that,
they did also leave me with
a deep belief in reason.
Not a shallow kind of
rationalism that believes
that the world is itself rational,
but a much more sober sort of
rationalism according to which
it is precisely because the
world is not a rational place
that reason is not only
possible but necessary.
They were, sort of, you
know a lot of my teachers,
Trilling, Shapiro, Berlin,
and like certain other
great figures in the modern world,
Freud, and Mann, and others,
they were rationalists
who were deeply interested
in the exploration of the non-rational,
because they recognized
what an important part
of reality non-reason is.
And so it wasn't it wasn't
rationalism as a bubble,
it was rationalism as a struggle,
as a really romantic struggle
to try to expand the realm,
expand the boundaries
of reason in human life.
- One of the ideas that
emerges in your writing
and especially in your
columns and The New Republic
is the extent to which a
totalist view often winds up
not relating to reality.
And it's very important, I gather for you,
that the ideas, you struggle
with ideas to form them,
but also they have to be
juxtaposition to reality.
- Yeah, I think that.
You know, I don't call myself, I mean,
I'm in some ways a scholar,
in some ways a journalist,
but when asked to, as
they say, self-describe,
the word I always use very
proudly is intellectual,
and what I mean by intellectual
is somebody who is competent
with and fluent with
the theoretical dimensions of ideas,
who genuinely cares about them.
but also insists upon
taking them to the world and into battle.
You know, there are certain people,
conservatives used to have this slogan
based on a book that was
written in the 1940s,
they used to say, ideas have consequences.
Now that's true, but it occurred to me,
many years ago I noticed
that many of the people
who say that were usually more interested
in the consequences than in the ideas.
And I think that one has to do both.
One has to do both.
One has to be genuinely committed
to the rigorous study of ideas,
almost as if they had no
application in the world,
and then one has to
take them to the world.
Now of course not all ideas.
There were some ideas that have no bearing
upon various issues of the day
and not everything is political.
In fact one of the main lessons I learned
from my education was
to be very, very strict
about policing the
boundaries of the political,
not to let everything be politicized.
And, you know, a poem is a poem.
The poem is not a political program.
And as an editor, I'm very
careful when pieces come in,
to be sure that I edit
various kinds of pieces
in ways that are appropriate to them.
A poem does not need to have an argument.
A poem does not need to
be even completely clear.
But if you're trying to persuade people
to vote for someone,
or to support a treaty,
or to support a war, or
not to support a war,
you damn well better be
clear and have arguments,
and take the arguments to the other side.
- As an intellectual, I get the sense,
you talk often about patience,
the patience and the
hard work that goes with.
- Patients is, patience is,
well, you know, it's certainly
one of the intellectual's
most difficult virtues.
Patience is a difficult
virtue everywhere almost.
But yes, I mean, you know,
the impatient liberal becomes a radical.
I mean, radical was a kind
of liberal impatience,
and if people who become
impatient with reform,
and for perfectly understandable reasons,
begin to fantasize or to plan revolution.
And the question of patience
has to do with the difference
between reform and revolution.
And it's a tricky question.
It does not have an easy answer.
There are certain questions
of first principle
about which a genuine
revolutionary attitude
would seem perfectly justified.
I always, the great
debate I've had in my head
with myself for decades,
the test case for me,
is 19th century America.
Is what sort of abolitionist
would I have been?
Would I have been a radical abolitionist
or a moderate abolitionist?
And the radical abolitionists
were calling for war.
And would I have called for war?
I'm not sure.
On the other hand war did come,
as a consequence in
part of that very issue.
You know, would I've been
a moderate abolitionist
because actually, I did not,
I would not have wanted to sacrifice
the entirety of the American
Union to the question
to the issue of slavery?
I'd like to think that
my loyalty to the Union
would have been that great,
but the evil of slavery
was also so spectacular
and this is something
I go round and round.
There are certain questions,
and the answers are not that obvious,
they're not that obvious.
But I try to err in the
direction of patience.
- So is it, what is your
view of Lincoln then?
Was he an ideal political leader
for mediating these problems?
- Yeah, Lincoln was a very
cunning political figure
who didn't get into it to end slavery,
but intended to end slavery.
- And navigated this.
- Yes, it was hard.
I mean, what would one's
view of John Brown have been?
He was a terrorist, out-and-out,
killed innocent people in Kansas,
killed them because he
thought slavery was evil.
You know, good and bad
means type situation.
But those are, you know,
and I'd like to think
that I would have denounced John Brown.
On the other hand, I'd like to think
I would not have denounced John Brown
in the way that some people
denounced John Brown,
out of a certain degree of complacency
or willingness to accept
this evil situation.
When you say the E word, when
you when you talk about evil,
it triggers a certain urgency
in the discussion, obviously.
And it's hard to be patient with evil,
and probably one should
not be patient with evil,
but one has to be clear
about what evil is,
and one has to think very carefully
about how one intends to combat it.
But the minute you find yourself fighting
what you regard as evil,
patience becomes very difficult
and not necessarily a virtue.
So these are not easy matters.
I don't have a formula for them.
- We'll pick up this thought in a minute,
but I wanna go back to
your formative experience,
because one part of your
formative experience
comes later in your life with the writing
of the book Kaddish, which.
Tell us about what your goal
was there in writing that book.
Your father has passed away and you assume
the responsibility of saying
Kaddish for him for a year.
- The immediate goal was as, look.
I was raised as an Orthodox Jew,
but I did not live as an Orthodox
Jew for many, many years.
But even when I was not living in that way
I knew that when the time would come
to do my duty as a mourner, I would do it,
because it's what my father
expected of me his whole life.
And it was not a question.
I mean, it was, so I began to do it,
and when I began to do it,
to do it means to appear in
synagogues three times a day
to utter this prayer
that says nothing about
mourning or death or pain,
it just is a series of praises of God.
They call it doxology.
And I began to do it,
and I began to understand
that I didn't know quite what I was doing.
And I decided I wanted to
find out what I was doing,
even though I intended to do it anyway.
You know, and this is true,
by the way, this was not as.
This is a melodramatic example,
but in fact it's usually the case in life
that we are already doing the actions
for which we are seeking reasons.
I mean, there is no
timeout that allows one
to figure out the reasons
for what one intends to do
and plan how one intends to live,
and then proceed and act on
this very well-reasoned plan.
That's not what life is like.
You find yourself performing
certain practices,
living according to certain
customs, religious, secular,
I mean all kinds, and you
begin to seek reasons for them.
And if you don't find reasons,
some of them you reject
and you stop practicing.
Though, some of them,
you have an attachment to
for non-rational reasons.
You have a love for them,
you believe they have a
positive, practical utility,
and so your failure to
find a reason for them
doesn't yet dissuade you
from practicing them,
and you keep looking for the reasons.
And others you find reasons for,
and it all works out in that way.
I mean, the whole relationship
of belief to action
works out neatly that way.
In this case I actually
set out to find out
what this prayer was, what
this custom was, and so on.
And not surprisingly, it
turned into an investigation
of some primary questions
about human existence.
I'm a very bookish man.
And whenever I'm perplexed or in trouble,
my tendency is to go to the bookshelf.
I began to go to my bookshelf,
which I have a very
considerable Jewish library,
to find medieval and ancient
texts to translate them
into English just for my own pleasure.
It wasn't until five or six
months into this 12-month period
that I even knew that
I was writing a book.
I was doing this to
make sense of it for me,
and if something came out of it
to be useful to other people.
Then about five or six months into it,
I realized that I was
writing a scholarly work
about the origins of this
Jewish custom of mourning,
a philosophical work
about death and mortality,
and a kind of spiritual journal.
And I began it, and the
genres became all mixed up.
And when I was writing it, I
had some anxieties about that.
I was like, what is it?
And then, as writers
discover when they're writing
something that has some inner necessity,
that was the key thing for me,
it's key thing for me
about any book or movie,
that it have some inner necessity,
when something has this inner necessity,
the questions of the genres,
all those external questions, fall away.
It is what it is.
The first couple of months
after my father's death,
I was smashed up emotionally,
and I was living this somnambulistic life,
getting up at these ungodly
hours to get to shul and so on.
So I wrote it in about 10 months,
and then permitted myself
the other two months
of the 12-month period
after the period was done
to kind of clean it up.
But it is it was written in real time.
It was written in real time.
At the very last minute, I
cut out about 40 or 50 pages
about my father and myself,
because I didn't want
the book to be mistaken
for another melodramatic
confessional about a boy,
a man and his dad.
This is not a psychological book.
I don't have much interest in psychology.
- So really, you were practicing
the work of being a scholar
and an intellectual as
part of a responsibility
that dictated by your
faith and your relationship
to your father.
- Yeah.
I have always believed
that study is a primary
spiritual expression.
And in the Jewish tradition,
it certainly is that.
And it was always my
primary religious expression
because, as I say, in terms
of behavior I was lapsed,
and I was always very bad at prayer,
for a whole variety of
philosophical reasons.
So study was, was my path, as it were.
And it was also, it was
temperamentally suited for me.
So yeah, I was a mourner,
scholar, thinker, diarist.
That's what I was doing.
- And you write that what you learned,
and I'm not saying this is
the only thing you learned,
that scripture and study
were the original occasion
for Kaddish, not mourning.
- Yeah, yeah, I mean, just as
a purely historical matter.
The Kaddish originated in
the Talmudical academies
in the Middle East, in what is now Iraq,
in the early medieval centuries.
And they are, the Kaddish,
as I said, is just,
it's a series of praises of
God, and it's in Aramaic.
This passage was used as
a kind of structural unit
to separate various aspects of the prayer
and to conclude study.
The earliest Kaddish we have,
at the end of any study
of Torah or Talmud,
there would be this prayer.
Now that particular Kaddish
actually refers to students
and the students of students and teachers,
and it's quite clear that
that is a kind of peroration after study.
A shorter version of it
became adapted to the liturgy,
just as a structural unit,
just as a kind of, you know,
as the ginger in the
sushI between the bites.
(Harry laughs)
And one of those structural
units then was adapted
for the purposes of mourning.
And that was the riddle for me, is why?
Why?
And that's what I set out to figure out.
Where and when it originated,
which I'm pretty satisfied I discovered.
And then, what it meant,
and then what it meant.
And that, what it meant,
involved getting into many, many sources
about the relationship
of parents to children
and the whole question of filial duty,
of parental responsibility, and so on.
- How did this exercise
affect you in your later life?
I mean, did it prove something to you
about what you wanted to do thereafter?
- No, I have to say.
You know the when the book appeared,
its reception was deeply
satisfying and somewhat surprising.
- [Harry] And it was nominated for a.
- It was nominated for
all kinds of things.
It won things, that stuff
doesn't interest me.
But certain things were said.
There was a certain traditional
Jewish response to it
that basically portrayed me
as the prodigal son who'd come back.
My response to that was always, look,
actually I never really
left as you think I did,
and I'm not quite as
back as you think I am.
(Harry chuckles)
Then there were those who thought
that it represented some
transformation in me.
That was incorrect.
In fact, Harold Bloom,
in a very favorable review of the book,
though not a very penetrating one,
he complained that the protagonist
of this book, the hero,
didn't change, didn't
undergo any transformation
in the way that heroes are supposed to.
And he was right.
I didn't.
I have to say, you know,
it took me decades,
but after much study and much thought,
I'd arrived at what I regarded
as a defensible picture of the world.
And before my father died
I knew that parents die,
Before I saw death, I
knew that death existed.
If you're a student of philosophy,
you've been studying these
questions long before
you've had occasion to experience them.
So no, this was more, it turned out to be,
and for this I was grateful,
it turned out to be
an opportunity for me to record
some of my understandings
of these questions,
but my life was not changed in that way.
- But was there a catharsis?
- There was a catharsis, certainly,
but the catharsis was in, I mean,
there was the filial catharsis,
the personal catharsis,
which came in the form of mourning.
I mean it was, you know, I mean,
life was suspended in some way for a year.
At first completely suspended,
then as the year wears on,
increasingly less and less suspended,
but still the mourner is, in Jewish law,
kind of pariah, does not
participate completely
in the society, in the community.
And it was a catharsis in
that I had managed to produce
what I regarded as a
satisfactory representation
of my views of certain things,
and to write a certain kind of book.
I mean, I have to say,
you know, I earn my living
as a certain kind of journalist.
I'm not, intellectually I'm
not primarily a journalist.
I've never reported on anything.
I don't regard the telephone
as an instrument of research.
(Harry laughs)
Never have.
I'm not that, so I'm not, I'm
not that sort of journalist.
- But you are a diarists,
that's what your column.
- Well, yeah, I'm a diarist.
But my diarist is,
it's a kind of (speaking
in foreign language).
It's a kind of old-fashioned,
late 19th century,
or 20th century European page
in which one writes about
anything one wants to write about
but in which one writes about them
with some learning and a certain amount
of philosophical resonance.
You know, I read the
polls about the election,
but I'm not going to write about them.
Everybody else is.
- You written about Jewish literacy
as a cultural problem for the
Jews in the United States.
You were not illiterate.
You were clearly steeped in lit,
and that made it quite a difference.
- As a Jew, I live mainly in Hebrew.
As a non-Jew, which I am too.
I mean there's the goy in me.
I live in English.
I live doubly.
I've always believed in living doubly
or tripling or quadruply.
Again, I told you, I'd, you
know, we live in many realms.
People who believe that
that human identity
must be seamlessly sewn
together so that it all adds up
into one brilliant and beautiful package.
I think that's an illusion.
I think it's a great
simplification of life.
So yes, I live doubly, and as a Jew,
I do most of my living in
Hebrew, with great pleasure,
because that's the natural,
that's the natural weather for Judaism.
I mean a language is your air,
and Judaism had a variety of languages,
but it's central language is Hebrew.
It doesn't happen in English.
And yes, I've written about it sometime,
but what I've done is
I've traveled the country,
far and wide, like an itinerant
fire and brimstone preacher,
just castigating Jews
for how little they know
in this regard.
- Does this problem
relate to Jewish attitudes
toward Israel.
- [Leon] No.
- That is understanding the
politics of that country.
- No
- No.
- No, early on in Israel's
history in the '50s and '60s
there was a certain American-Jewish
enthusiasm for Israel,
a certain American-Jewish Zionism
that impelled people to go learn Hebrew,
and there were these institutions
called (speaking in foreign language)
that were basically Hebrew
classes taught by Israelis.
And there was that period,
but that period passed.
And now, of course, most
Israelis prefer to speak English
with their American-Jewish brethren.
And you know, I've thought for years
that the day that Haaretz posted
a daily English translation
of its newspaper,
it practically doomed the fate of Hebrew,
and it doomed Hebrew in the
American-Jewish community.
No, Israel is not why
American Jews need Hebrew
or should know Hebrew.
Judaism is why they should know Hebrew.
They should know their civilization,
- Now you've written things
about the Israeli government
that separates.
- [Leon] I have.
- That criticism, criticism that you make,
from support of Israel.
Is this a subtle distinction
that escapes the Jewish community?
I mean, that is the notion.
- I think it escapes lots of people.
Again, we get back to this question
of living or thinking doubly.
I think that Israel has mortal enemies
and needs to defend itself ferociously.
And I think that unless the
Palestinians get a state,
the Jewish state will not survive,
and that Israel has been
unconscionably delinquent
in pursuing a solution
with the Palestinians.
Not just this government,
some former governments too,
but especially this government.
And I've insisted that one has
to speak both these thoughts
in the same breath and
think them at the same time.
And that it is not the case
that if if there should be it,
that because there should
be a two-state solution,
we need not worry about the
Iranian nuclear capability.
And it is not the case that
because the Iranians may want
to acquire a nuclear weapon
that the Israelis don't have to worry
to find a solution with the Palestinians.
People have got to learn
to do a bunch of things at the same time.
Now, each camp ideologically
in the Jewish world,
in the IsraelI political world, prefers.
They have their preferred threat,
and some of that, I say that,
that's a little more cynical
than I mean it to sound.
They may actually sincerely have arrived
at the conclusion that there
is one overwhelming threat.
I don't see one overwhelming threat.
I see a variety of very serious threats.
And they all have to be addressed.
And I see nothing incompatible
with a robust response
to the Iranian attempt to
acquire a nuclear weapon.
And we can discuss what a robust
response means if you want.
And a robust attempt to
find a way to establish
the state of Palestine
alongside the State of Israel.
I'm an old Peace Now guy.
I've always thought that the
only solution to this problem
are two states.
It was always the only solution.
It used to be called partition.
It's the same idea.
Both peoples have the rights to the land.
Neither people can have the whole land.
Neither people who's leaving the land,
both peoples have to live in peace.
The only, the only solution
is to divide the land.
I mean, that's since
the Peel Commission proposed it in 1936.
That seems to have been the only morally
and practically sound solution.
And somehow, we cannot get there.
- So what does a robust response
to the Iranian challenge?
- I am very, I have dark
thoughts about this subject.
Not dark thoughts of the
sort you might think.
I'm not persuaded
that there is any military
solution to this problem.
I do not believe that the
Israelis can have 'em,
can provide a military solution to it.
The Israelis, I think,
understand that, that they can't.
I don't think they any
longer believe that,
which explains some of Netanyahu's
otherwise inexplicable behavior
in the last six months.
And the question is first,
does the United States have the capability
to provide a military
solution to this problem?
And B, would the United States be willing,
or should the United States
be willing to do this?
And one can have many answers to this.
The only solution to the
Iranian nuclear question
is democratic change in Iran.
I've no doubt about that.
Problem is that the
democracy clock is ticking
much more slowly than the nuclear clock.
If there is a military
strike against Iran,
I imagine they can cripple the facilities
for two or three years.
They can set it back.
I then imagine that the next morning,
the Iranians will start to dig more deeply
into a different mountain.
There will be no damage assessment.
We won't know what we've accomplished.
I don't worry about the
response in the region
in the sense that I think
the Iranians would unleash
Hezbollah against Israel,
which would be, there
would be another war there,
and I'm not taking that lightly,
though the IsraelI army's
kind of itching to get there,
to destroy that arsenal,
But I believe that any attempt by anybody
to setback or destroy the
Iranian nuclear program
would be welcomed joyously by the Saudis
and the Gulf states and Egypt and so on.
But, so, I don't really
have a solution to this
in the sense that I'm
increasingly not of the belief
that there is a military solution.
- You've written about the Arab Spring
as someone who, in
looking at his principles,
leans on the side of
humanitarian intervention.
- [Leon] Absolutely.
- And I wanna explore that
because it it may be a place
to test this idea of having principles
but relating them to reality.
So I would be interested in
in your intellectual struggle
to come to the conclusion you come.
You've been very critical
of the Obama administration,
- I have.
- on Syria, but supportive
of their action in Libya.
- Absolutely.
I think that the Arab Spring
is the most strategically,
historically important event
since 1988, '88, '89 in Europe.
I think that the possibility
of political progress
and social progress in the Arab world,
its ramifications are so far-reaching,
that it must be supported.
I think that having said that,
one must understand that democratization
is a very difficult and brutal process.
That it is a process,
That democratization is
not an event, it's an era.
And you have to keep your head,
because it doesn't happen
in a day or a week.
When you liberate people,
you liberate the actually existing people
who may merely wish to be free
to return to some of their
old autocratic prejudices.
The turmoil, the confusion,
the relative success so far
of certain Islamist forces
doesn't surprise me.
It worries me, of course,
but it doesn't surprise me.
The blame for the rise
of these Islamist forces
is not the democratic
revolution, its Mubarak.
The dictators are responsible
for the rise of the Islamists,
because the Islamists
are all that was left
after the dictators
gutted their society of all its politics.
Morsi is the direct result of
Mubarak, not of Tahrir Square.
So I think that these must be supported.
I think the United States
should support democratic
stirrings and revolts
just about everywhere,
just about everywhere.
I think Obama did not support it
adequately or in time in Egypt.
Finally came around.
I think liberty intervention in Libya
was the right thing to do.
I think that our failure to intervene,
and I don't mean by invading,
but to intervene in Syria.
is an act of such stupidity
and moral callousness.
It reminds me of what it was
like in the first 2 1/2 years
of the Bosnian genocide.
It took Clinton 2 1/2
years to go in and stop it.
And by the time he stopped it,
a quarter of a million
people had been killed
Everything, everything that
Obama said would happen
if we intervened is
happening because we didn't.
Everything.
It is now a sectarian civil war,
there are jihadi elements
that are arriving in Syria.
It is destabilizing the region.
It is spilling over into Turkey,
it is spilling over into Jordan,
it is spilling over spectacularly
last week into Lebanon.
Everything that was supposed to happen
as a result of our
intervention is happening
because the West did nothing.
We are just watching it.
And he intones these
high-minded statements
that are, sound more and more cynical.
As far as I can tell, he
has absolutely no intention.
- Obama.
- The moral argument for intervening
seems pretty clear to me.
This man is massacring his people.
I mean, he's massacring children.
The massacre of children,
it has played an especially central role
in the Syrian rebellion,
in the way that the rape
of women did in Bosnia.
It was sort of that extra
touch of evil as an instrument,
and that extra instrument of war.
But there's not only a moral argument,
there's a strategic argument,
which is that, and the
strategic stakes in Syria
are much higher than they
were in Libya, much higher.
And the fall of the Assad regime
would deliver a body blow
to the Iranian government
to the regime in Tehran,
and nothing is more in
the strategic interest
of the United States in that region
than to weaken, and cripple,
and ultimately to see
replaced the regime in Tehran.
- On this issue, a realist might say,
and I want you to respond
to this criticism,
that you're not showing the patience
that is Obama's virtue in in this process.
- But remember I said earlier
that there are certain,
there are certain events or certain things
that again, the patience
question is complicated.
Showing patience in a
humanitarian emergency
represents a fundamental misunderstanding
of the nature of the emergency.
If the problem is that innocent
men, women, and children
are being massacred, then if
you don't stop it immediately,
you've misunderstood the problem here.
You don't take your time
stopping a massacre.
Again, to use the
imperfect medical analogy,
if you discover that you
have a tumor that needs
immediate, dramatic treatment,
you don't escalate, you nuke it.
Which is why people get
rushed to the hospital
and their lives change overnight.
Because the only meaningful response,
the only effective response,
is an immediate response
and a significant response.
So I think it, when it comes
to the stopping of atrocities,
conferences and escalation and,
it is the opposite.
It is actually a way of,
that form of doing
something is the worst way
of doing nothing.
But, again, if you want to talk about it
from a cold-hearted,
realistic perspective,
just look at the map.
The overthrow of Assad would
be devastating to Iran,
devastating to Hezbollah,
devastating to Russia.
Strategically, these are all
goods for the United States.
These are all goods.
I don't see, I don't see that now is.
The argument, the realists
say, but there will be chaos.
To which I respond, but there is chaos.
There already is chaos.
And the reason there's chaos
is because we've been passive.
One of the reasons, you know.
There is chaos.
They say it will be an
ethnic sectarian war.
It is an ethnic sectarian war.
It wasn't a year ago,
it wasn't a year ago.
So I think that our policy
on Syria has been disastrous
and should disqualify
Obama from dining out
on the Libyan example any further.
- You actually believe
that humanitarian
internationalism is a way,
one of the great contributions
of the United States.
- I think that American
power can be used for good
and should be used for good.
- [Harry] Yeah.
- I think the fact that
it's been used for ill
does not mean that can
never be used for good.
You know, but again,
I believe that one has to judge each case.
I supported the Iraq
war because I believed.
I believed what I was told,
that there are weapons of
mass destruction there,
and more to the point,
because Saddam Hussein
had already used them.
The important fact about
Saddam Hussein was Halabja,
was the chemical warfare
against his own people.
- [Harry] The Kurds.
- The Kurds.
But they were Iraqi Kurds.
And I thought, I don't have to speculate
about the willingness
of this man to use them.
He's already shown that he can.
When it became clear to me
that there were no weapons
of mass destruction,
I recanted my support immediately,
though I did say that my feelings
about the origins of the war,
it shed no light on what the
outcome of the war might be,
and that Iraq without Saddam Hussein,
with this groping towards
some sort of parliamentary, open system,
will be, may turn out to be a blessing.
But if I'd known there were no
weapons of mass destruction,
I would not have done what Bush did.
Afghanistan, by contrast, was a war
that I thought was perfectly justified,
not only so as to extirpate the people
who committed the act of terror
in New York, and Pennsylvania,
and Washington against us,
but also because the kind of
collateral humanitarian effect
of destroying the Taliban
also seem justified to me.
So my problem became then that,
but after not just 10
years now, but eight years,
it became clear to me that
the Afghans don't want it.
They just want our protection.
Every time we go in, they're fine.
When we move away, the
Taliban come right back.
We're supposed to come back
in the next fighting season,
clear it out, and they'll be fine,
and would they welcome us
then the Taliban come back.
So I actually, where the Afghan war
seemed perfectly justified
to me and still does,
I gave up on it about
a couple of years ago.
And it's all on a case-by-case thing.
I do think that when there are
what I call moral emergencies,
and obviously some of this
has to do with reflection
on the failure of any
power to come to the rescue
of people like my parents
during the Second World War.
That's kind of textbook obvious.
But still, I think that is
the that is the paragon.
When certain atrocities at
a certain level take place,
I think anyone with the power to stop it
has a responsibility to stop it.
In most cases the United States
is the one with the power to stop it,
and in almost all cases the United States
is the only one that will
entertain the argument
for stopping it.
So yes, you know, I don't think
we're ever in danger of being
the policemen of the world.
I really don't.
- Because of the politics.
- Yeah, yeah, I mean people talk about,
you know in the last decade,
people have talked
about the United States,
because of Iraq and
Afghanistan, as an empire.
The British were in India
for 200 years, right.
We can't be in a place for
200 months before it starts.
No, we're not, that's, I don't believe
that wild excessive
intervention is the danger.
I think that American
diffidence about the world,
you can call it isolationism,
you call it what you want,
is the danger.
I think that the economic
analysis of strategic realities
is the danger.
It's not all about money.
Even if China owns whatever percentage
of our Treasury bills that they own,
when people are in trouble,
when Syrians are in trouble,
or Iranians are in trouble,
or Haitians are in trouble
after an earthquake,
or Japanese are in trouble
after a nuclear plant melts down,
they don't go to China or
Brazil, they come to us.
And quite rightly, because they know
that we're the people who
not only have the capacity,
the capability to help them,
but who will entertain
the thought of helping.
We will actually consider doing this.
- To change subjects,
because you wear many hats,
and I'm trying to touch on all of them.
Let's talk about the
changes at The New Republic
and being a literary editor.
And what I have in mind here is
the tradition that you represent
is really generally threatened
by the commercialization of publishing,
by the web and so on.
How do we navigate these transitions
and preserve the kinds of
traditions that you are all about
in in terms of a liberal
literary tradition?
- That's a complicated question.
I think that the pressures
on serious thought
and serious writing in America
were always very great.
And people who held my job,
which is a distinguished
little perch in American life,
I mean I sit in Edmund Wilson's chair,
and Malcolm Cowley chair,
and Alfred Kazin's chair,
and people like that
were always complaining
about yahoo-ism and
middlebrow-ism and midcult,
and there were always these pressures.
And the advocacy and the defense
of serious thought and serious writing
was always a kind of embattled activity.
You're right that in recent decades
it's become increasingly embattled.
The main threat, obviously, at
the very beginning at least,
seemed technological,
seemed technological.
And there was this
deranged, dizzy first period
in the history of the internet
when it seemed that it
would overwhelm everything.
You know, I used to say
that they finally invented
a medium of communication
with no limitations
of physical space, and
everything had to be 400 words.
(Harry laughs)
And of course it had to do with the speed.
It's all, but the technology
is all about the speed.
Now that has shaken out a little bit.
That is shaken out a little bit.
I see this in my work,
I see it everywhere.
One can make the argument,
which I do sometimes,
and which I mean, one has to,
that if one wishes to
preserve what we recognize
as an experience of serious reading,
then the tablet can provide
such an experience as well.
The web, the internet,
blogging, all that stuff,
if it had never been invented
that would have been fine with me.
Though I understand
that there are doctors,
and scientists, and dissidents,
who find uses for this
technology, and so on.
But I was, you know, life
was quite fast enough for me,
thank you, before all this.
But the fact is that
the tablet does provide
an experience of a page.
It's one of the things that
we'll be experimenting with
at The New Republic now, is this.
My view has been that
that just because there were new bottles
doesn't mean that the old wine is bad.
There was, as I say in this first period
of the internet dizziness
this view that if there are
new bottles, we need new wine.
It has to be shorter, it has to be faster,
it has to be linked, it
has to be hyperlinked,
it has to, et cetera.
That's, whoever wants to
stay linked and hyperlinked
and stay in the echo chamber can and will,
and it's fine, it exists.
But the, you know, this technology
now has been routinized.
It's, everybody uses it
at all levels of American
culture, of American life.
So the challenge now is to find ways
to put the old bottle, the
old wine in the new bottles.
And to keep the old
wine in the old bottles.
What would, I mean,
this is a little bit of
a complicated metaphor,
but I think of what we're trying
to do with my magazine now
is to preserve the old wine
in the old bottles and the new bottles.
So we're, we have a, I mean,
this young man who bought
the, acquired the magazine,
one of the Facebook guys,
is an extraordinarily thoughtful man.
I mean, I've gotten to know him,
and he's been supportive of
all the magazine's strengths,
and he's interested in
what people now refer
to as long-form writing,
but that means essays,
and developed arguments,
and serious criticism.
And so my responsibility,
his responsibility,
our responsibility, is not to mistake
a technological revolution for
an intellectual revolution,
and to use the new technology
to create and proliferate
the old discourse, which
is still necessary.
You see I've always looked
that there are still a large number
of serious people in this country,
all the distractions and
temptations notwithstanding.
They're there.
We could quadruple our circulation
without having to create one new reader.
We just have to find the
natural readers who are there.
So in that sense, I'm not pessimistic.
In that sense, I'm not pessimistic.
What I'm more pessimistic about are,
is whether this new,
wired culture of ours,
with its new interests, and so on,
will continue to produce
the sort of students
and graduate students, or
young writers and thinkers,
who will want to inherit
the old discourse.
I have to think it will.
My greatest challenge as an editor,
and my greatest pleasure as an editor,
is in finding the heirs.
Nothing gives me greater
pleasure than to find the heirs.
I find them.
I look hard, I find them.
They're good.
It can still happen.
- Which touches on a question
that I want to ask you.
This amazing tradition
that you were exposed to,
where are the places for
training the next generation.
They're not in the
universities, or are they?
- Well that's the problem.
I mean, I think they might.
No, they may not be any longer.
You know, there was a period in the '80s
where a certain kind of traditional
humanistic criticism gave way.
First to certain kinds of literary theory
and then to certain, what's
called, sociological approaches,
having to do with race,
class and gender and so on.
Things were intensely
politicized and so on.
I think that battle has
been fought and largely won.
I'm not that worried about that anymore.
I think that the problem is that,
in part owing to the
technology but not only,
young people now are taught
mainly to game things.
To game their courses,
to game their grades,
to game their applications.
- So it's economism.
- It's economism.
It's this thing that
they're taught to worship
which is pragmatism.
I mean, as a philosophy
and as a view of life,
I don't like pragmatism.
As my as my old friend and teacher
Sydney Morgenbesser once said,
the only problem with pragmatism
is that it doesn't work.
(Harry laughs)
I think, I don't believe in it.
And I think that everything,
the smartest question
you can ask in America right now
that young people are taught to ask
is not whether something is true or false,
or good or bad, or ugly or beautiful,
but how does it work?
How does it work?
That's all anybody wants to know.
And the really smart
thing you could say is,
no it doesn't work that way,
this is how it really work.
That's the esoteric knowledge
that establishes you.
Obviously, at a certain level,
one has to know how things work,
but how things work is
not the reason to live.
It's not the reason to write,
it's not the reason to have a family,
it's not the reason to have a community,
it's not the reason to have a country.
We don't have these things
because of how things work.
We have them because we hold
certain ideals, or values, or beliefs
that we have to remember how to defend.
So, I worry about these
things, I worry about these.
- How would you advise students
to prepare for the future,
then, in this kind, yeah.
- Well.
Right now, it's a tricky
question because of the recession
and people worried about
jobs and making a living,
and I understand that.
An old friend of mine many
years ago once said that
the reason so many
intellectuals could come up
during the Depression is
because everybody was broke.
(Harry laughs)
Didn't matter if you were the broke one,
because the bankers were broke too.
So there is, I understand,
I understand the anxiety.
But I do think that
society gives young people
four years in their lives in
which they can read and think,
only four years.
I keep telling young people this.
When I hear, when I meet young people
who are accelerating college,
I tell them they're mad,
they're absolutely mad.
They'll never get it back.
And I think that I'm one of those,
I hold out for the humanities.
I think that people in college
should be force-fed the
humanities if necessary,
because whatever they retain
is going to affect them
in the deepest ways.
And they'll figure out how things work.
They'll get there.
I mean everybody's going,
and they'll figure it out.
You know, we're not, this
society is not suffering
from a surfeit of people with
their heads in the clouds.
That's not the problem.
You know, we have young people
who were cold-blooded realists
at preternaturally early ages
so we're not suffering
from too many idealists
or too many poets, that's
not the problem we face.
And I think college should
offer a certain resistance
to the practical frame of mind.
Now, it's hard, I see this.
I have a nephew at Columbia right now,
and I hear stories from.
It's hard, it's hard.
Everything needs to be gamed,
everything needs to be gamed.
- You talk about the
end-state of perfection,
but more important is the capability
to become more perfect.
- Yeah, yeah, no, perfect.
You know, it's funny,
it's the distinction between
perfection and perfectibility.
You know what, there is a
16th century Jewish thinker
who wrote in an essay on frivolity
something that's always
meant a great deal to me.
He wrote that, he said that,
human beings are the creatures
who are in their nature,
in their definition,
perfectible, who aspire to perfection.
He pointed out that
if that is the defining
characteristic of the human,
then in such a creature, in
a creature whose essence,
whose essence is to aspire to perfection,
perfection itself will
be regarded as a flaw.
Because that's not what we're
not supposed to be perfect,
we're supposed to be
aspiring to perfection.
And that just, a great
deal of wisdom can be found
in that distinction, a great deal.
You know, people who
believe they're perfect
are always wrong.
Our current president is an example, yes.
But people who aspire to perfection
accomplish extraordinary things,
because they, and they do it
because the aspiration to
perfection somehow manages
to bring the ideal and the
critical frame of mind together,
to yolk them together,
and one doesn't fall away from the other.
And that's the key, that's the key.
So that's the distinction
that I would make.
- Well on that positive
note, actually, I'd like to
thank you very much.
- My pleasure.
- For coming on our program.
- Well thank you.
- And thank you very much
for joining us for this
conversation with history.
(rhythmic synthesizer music)